Bars, what's your question?
>> No, I don't really have a question, uh,
Sam, but I just wanted to say thanks for
everything that you do. Uh, even God
logic as well. I had the opportunity
last month to go on a couple of his
lives in the guest box.
And uh, I had denounced Islam on
December 18th, 2025. So,
>> you renounce Islam?
>> I did. I did.
>> Did you convert to Islam? Uh I I
reverted in 2024.
>> So you didn't last more uh two years.
Glory to Jesus Christ. You left that
filthy.
>> Yeah. Um
>> well I'm 29 years old now and I had
always been intrigued at the time about
Islam since I was 17 years old. And uh
the masjid and the community as a whole
that I had always kept in touch with um
wasn't really a good experience as a
whole. Um there were some interesting
sketches others that I had come across
that definitely made me question Islam a
lot but then on the other side of the
coin I wanted to keep the root of the
faith and you know just to continue to
dive and dig in on my own but I wasn't
getting the answers that I was needing
but like I said it was just a constant
coin flip like okay I'm seeing a lot of
cons here but for some odd reason at the
same time the religion was bringing me
peace at that time in my life and I was
like I have to keep digging and I have
to keep being and I was getting nowhere.
It was like I was literally a mole
constantly digging different routes with
no ending. And when I had finally came
across God Logic and you know seeing
your videos pop up and David Wood and
you guys were always constantly debating
the Muslims, I'm like, "Okay, now let me
kind of take my route this way and see
what's going on on both sides." And what
was interesting overall,
uh, like I said, being intrigued about
it since I was 17 and I'm 29 now, when I
seen God logic and you know, you and
David Wood and everybody else bringing
it up about the uh, Elzoot hadith
>> and the marriage
>> and the marriage controversy with
Muhammad and Aisha. I put this on a
polygraph test and I put this on God.
out of the years that I had always been
intrigued and even when I reverted in
2024,
I had never knew the whole age
difference, the gigantic sickening age
difference of Muhammad and Aisha or the
Alzoo hadith. I had never knew anything
about it. And when I had jumped into God
Logic Stream a couple of times, like I
said last month, I had took that
information and brought it to the Sheek
and I was like, "Hey man, like I'm
having uh some concerns here." And
interesting enough, when I had drove
back to the mosque to bring this
information to him, I was there prior
that same evening to finish off the
evening prayer. I went back home and I
was like, man, like this is just really
bothering me. I was like, you know what?
I'm gonna drive back down to the mosque.
Maybe Shea is having like a late night
study to himself since he's in college.
>> Let me go see if he's there. Sure
enough, he was there. And I was like,
okay, this must be a sign. So, I go in
and I'm like, "Hey, Sheek, you know,
salamikum, all that, you know, salami
bacon stuff. We have a conversation. We
have a conversation and sit down and I
was like, "Hey, I need to I need to
bring something to your attention. I'm
having some concerns." And he's like,
"Yeah, yeah, sure. What's going on?" I
said, "Have you ever heard of the hadith
of Alz?"
And according to him, he said he never
knew or heard of what it was, but he
wanted some explanation and elaboration.
And I told him about it. I said, "Hey,
like, you know, I heard that Muhammad
had this little companion scroll writer
named Iben Mazud who tagged along with
him." And then say again,
>> Yeah. Iben Massud. So yeah, when you
showed it to him, what did he say?
>> Yeah. And I told him that whole story
and he was like, "Nope, that's uh
blasphemy. That's propaganda from the
Christians. That hadith is weak. It's
not authentic. I've never heard of it.
Do you have any other questions?" And I
said, "Okay." I said, "So, what about
the whole marriage controversy with
Muhammad and Aisha?
>> You know, Muhammad at that time was in
his late 50s. He had married Aisha at
six and physically fondled her at the
age of nine."
>> I said, "What what is going on with
this?" Uh I was like, "Is that another
weak Hadith? Is this false? Is this
propaganda?" Like, "What's your
response?" And he goes, "Well, I'm going
to be completely honest with completely
honest with you. Um that was God's will
and it was allowed."
>> And it took a lot of a lot of holding
back internally the moment I had to
process that to just not physically go
off on him for condoning pedophilia. And
>> I asked him out loud rhetorically. I
said, "So you're telling me that God
permitted
a fullgrown
late 50-year-old man to do this to a
kid?" And he said, "Well, are the
prophets perfect?"
>> And I said, and I said, "Dude, I was
like, you know what?" I said, "The
prophet, the prophets have their own
stories, but nothing like this." So I
was like, "Well, I'm going to ask you my
other question then, more on the
Christian side." I said, "Who is Isaiah
chapter or yeah, chapter 53:3-5
talking about?" And I was like, "Is it
Jesus?" And he's like, "Well, I have no
experience or knowledge with the Bible,
but we're going to call one of the
brothers that does." So, we called him,
explained all of this all over again,
and the first thing out of his mouth
was, "Don't trust the Christians.
They're nasty. Don't trust the God
logic. I see all the debates on
YouTube." You know, you know, Brother
Bo, uh, well, I mean, obviously, he said
my actual name, but for the sake of the
live stream, he goes, "Brother Bo,"
>> he's like, "Don't trust them." And the
whole thing with Isaiah 53 3-5, it has
nothing to do with Jesus, it's just
talking about the old covenant and the
new covenant of the of the Jews. And you
know, either way, after concluding all
that conversation, I I walked back out.
I said, "Hey, check. Have a good night.
I'll see you next time." Which I already
knew in my head I was never going back.
I drove down the road. There was a
Christian church literally down the
street. I go in there, the janitor lets
me in, and I said, "Hey, man. like, I
know this is kind of awkward. It's after
hours, you know, can I uh can I just sit
in the chapel for a little bit? I just
need to reflect on some things. He's
like, "Yeah, yeah, go ahead." So, he
waited in the lobby for me while I, you
know, went in there and I literally
asked God. I was like, "Hey." I was
like, "I need some guidance, especially
after what has happened.
You know, if you are real, show me
something." Because I've been intrigued
about Islam for a long, long time. you
know, just trying to pave a path of my
own, even though I've had a lot of bad
experiences within the community, but
I'm still trying to keep the faith with
this. But obviously, after the responses
that I got tonight, please guide me in
the direction, you know, that I need to
get to. So, I left the chapel and I told
the janitor, I said, "Hey, thanks for
letting me utilize the chap uh the
chapel for the night." And there was a
couple gentlemen that came out of this
corridor within the chapel. And one of
them was actually the pastor. And, you
know, I just kind of recapped with him
what was going on. And I just said,
"Hey, I'm just trying to, you know, seek
guidance if you have a free Bible or
like a little scripture pamphlet, you
know, can I have one?" So, he gave me a
free Bible and also just like a little u
pamphlet of some sort of the gospels and
yeah, I went back to God Logic Extreme
and I told him everything that happened
and I announced it on December 18th,
2025. So,
>> all right. Glory to Jesus. Now, grow in
your faith, understanding of the faith,
man, and be a witness. But learn your
faith first and be faithful, bro. Shoot.
Yeah. No, I'm trying. Um, the Bible that
I have currently here, let me go grab it
in the kitchen real quick.
>> Yeah, there's also Bibles online like
biblegateway.com.
>> Okay, I will definitely jot that down.
>> Is right. The one I'm using right here,
biblegateway.com.
It has dozen versions all for free right
here. Biblegateway.com.
>> Okay, got that. And then the one that I
do have is the message, the Bible in
contemporary language by Eugene
Peterson. paraphrase. It's a paraphrase.
So, if you want, I I'm going to send it
to you in private chat. Start reading
NIV. It's a little more literal, but
it's a paraphrase. Your way up. All
right.
>> Okay. Sounds good. Well,
>> and watch the material and learn your
faith, brother.
>> Sounds good, brother. Well, it's good to
finally spiritually keep doing what
you're doing. Jesus has always had his
hand on you, and you know, I pray that
he does the same for me. So,
>> he has his hand on you. That's why he
didn't let you go and you came back. So,
of course, he'll never leave nor forsake
you. So, get faithful, get strong, and
grow, my brother.
>> Sounds good, brother. I'm going to save
your email in the chat as well. Is that
okay? Can I save that just in case I
need to reach out?
>> Just make sure though, check because 98%
of questions have been answered on the
websites and the YouTube channel. So,
find your answers there and then if not,
then we'll take it from there.
>> Sounds good. Have a good night, sir.
Bye.
>> God bless you.
Okay, let's go full screen. Follow me.
Glory to the father spirit. It is very
humbling and even scary because of the
responsibility I have before the lord
that the lord was pleased to find me as
a teenager and as I cried out for
answers to give me the answers to these
questions in such a way that annihilates
destroys obliterates these blasphemies.
Why I say it's humbling? Because I'm no
better than the next guy. I'm not more
deserving than the next guy. If God
gives me what I deserve, I go to hell.
And yet the Lord in his love and
compassion was just pleased to give me
this wisdom. It's humbling and it's
scary.
And that's why I ask you to pray for me.
God, reign me in, own me, and keep me
humble. I never get puffed up and think
I'm special because once that happens,
I'm useless to the Lord, but it is
humbling and scary for this kind of
wisdom to be given. It's mind-blowing
and it's humbling. So, thank you, Lord
Jesus. See, sometimes I have to stop and
reflect because it at times it blows me
away because I'm not more deserving than
any of my siblings. I'm the youngest of
six, but God was pleased to single me
out. It's just humbling. It said scary
to.